it was Gaga who got the royal treatment
at the Venice Film Festival with Bradley
Cooper a star is born this way
[Music]
thousands of pink ostrich feathers a
Couture Valentino gown Gaga was a
standout wearing the same style Chaya
Gerber rocked on the runway this summer
[Music]
Gaga's worn five outfits in the past
three days
her best accessory handsome mr. Cooper
this morning Gaga got emotional gushing
about him as her co-star and director I
remember very very well I walked down
the stairs from my house before we
filmed the screen test
for a star is born and he had a makeup
wife in his hand and he put his hand on
my face and he went like this and there
was makeup we had put just a little bit
and he said he said I want no makeup on
your face
and so this vulnerability was something
that he brought out in me Hey what I
just want to take another look at you
watching her sing it was insane all of a
sudden she starts and you know the
temperature in the room changes I've
always wanted to be an actress and there
can be a hundred people in the room and
99 don't believe in you and you just
need one to believe in you and that was
him so I'm very lucky to be here the
first review is in from The Hollywood
Reporter they say that there's a lot to
love this movie is made with heart and
grit so we are even more excited to see
it as stars born opens in the States
October 5th
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]